I think you're going to like this next
story Devin Nunez is a Republican
congressman he's filthy okay he's been
wrapped up with the White House and with
the sketchiness of trying to have
foreign powers smear Joe Biden way back
when
before the 2018 midterms when the house
Intel committee was working was
investigating Trump Nunez was on the
committee and he was going to the White
House to tell Trump what they were doing
he has been traveling around the world
for meetings that he shouldn't be having
and he was one of the people asking
questions during the house intelligence
committees impeachment hearings just a
couple of months ago when in reality he
should have been a witness right he
should have been on the receipt he
should have been answering questions not
asking them because of his involvement
so one of the things that was alleged a
couple months ago was that Devin Nunez
had been in touch directly with Rudy
Giuliani's henchmen left Parnas by phone
let me remind you the connection Donald
Trump has a personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani Rudy Giuliani is peddling
influence and getting smear campaigns
going to help Donald Trump Rudy has two
henchmen working for him or used to
until they were indicted left Parnas and
igor freamon they go all over the world
they do dirty work they're doing
surveillance on people they're making
deals influencing people doing Trump's
bid bidding through Rudy Giuliani when
it was previously alleged thanks to
leaked phone records that Devin Nunez
had direct phone calls with left Parnas
he couldn't remember it he denied it it
didn't figure anything in his memory now
we knew he was lying it was suggested
maybe someone took Devin's phone and
called Lev Parnas if you can believe
that
check this out from December you know
what what did you discuss with loved
arnis well I don't even know because I
don't I've never met paar nos and like I
filed in federal court and so you know
it's a great question because many
people want to know including myself so
you know you're having a phone
conversation with him we we have not
been able to confirm that yet you I mean
you don't you don't think you would
remember if you had a you have to you
have to remember you have to remember we
are the House Intelligence Committee
Oversight Committee okay so we get calls
from people every day all all walks of
life I get them from all over the world
now at the time if you could read
between the lines
you could tell that he was lying I have
never met Lev Parnas well we're talking
about phone calls
did you talk on the phone we've not been
able to confirm that I talked on the
phone with him I get many calls from
different people very transparently
lying but cut to last night or the night
before actually Rachel Maddow
on MSNBC interviews Rudy Giuliani's
henchman Lev Parnas and what a
coincidence right after Lev Parnas tells
Rachel Maddow everybody was involved
Trump all the way down
Devon Nunez suddenly remembers the phone
call check this out Devon Nunez back on
Fox News
two nights ago talking about it
something seems to have jogged his
memory and you know you have to remember
this is someone a matter of fact I think
I came on your show Martha this person
accused me of being in Vienna him and
his lawyers accused me of being in
Vienna meeting with Ukrainians in 2018
with him I mean this is someone who
doesn't tell the truth it's something
that didn't happen so this person has a
real problem with the truth not to
mention he's been indicted very very
strange so and we also talked back then
about the fact that your phone number
showed up with calls to him to live
Parnas in in a like list of data numbers
and you said that you didn't recall
speaking with him or whether it was on
your cell phone or your office phone
have you have you figured out the answer
to any of the if you recall that was
brand-new when that account when I came
on your show I just didn't know the name
this name Parr knows so you know what I
always like to remind people is you know
we are dealing with people every day
we're an oversight committee so we have
incoming calls that come to my office to
my cell phone etc etc and then you know
you know now that he had called my cell
phone and I didn't know his name I
didn't remember the name but I did
remember going back looking at where I
was at the time because you know you can
do that now you actually know where you
physically are checked it with my
records and it was very clear I remember
I remember that call which was very odd
random talking about random things and I
said great you know just talk to my
staff and boom a boom and that's which
is Ukraine an ambassador there was note
was there any discussion about the
Ukrainian ambassador and the fact that
she should be removed in that call well
the first time I remember the name
Jovanovic the ambassador was not until
this impeachment sham started total liar
can't be trusted oh I denied the phone
calls but I did talk to him but he's the
guy that you can't trust great he
remembers the call and he remembers
talking about random things does anybody
believe that left Parnas had a random
call with Devon Nunez who Nunez didn't
know but still pass to staff for
follow-up so of course the goalposts are
being moved first there was no
recollection of the call left Parnas
doesn't ring a bell
what are people talking about now it's
you know I did get a call from him I
remember that it was just a random call
but I did pass it to my staff for
follow-up we'll follow up about what if
it was a random call about nothing none
of it is believable and also does anyone
believe that Devon Nunez was in touch
with trump Parnas and Giuliani all along
and never heard the name Marie
Ivanovitch uttered until the impeachment
hearing started he's coming up with more
lies unforced lies unless maybe they are
forced because we don't understand how
deep in it he is and he is one of the
most dishonest players in this entire
thing let me know what you think I'm on
twitter at des Pakman I do want to hear
from you do you feel like you just don't
have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that there are just not
enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink accom slash Pakman what
blinka studs is take thousands of
popular non-fiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work
I've just finished listening to upheaval
by Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a
tremendous author whose work I've
previously recommended excellent book
some of modern history's biggest
national crises to figure out how
different countries ended up in such
precarious situations plinkus has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for bling cast
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you